under the cover of the pandemic we've
seen a massive shift in wealth from the
poorest to the richest a partying pm and
a law-breaking ritualist chancellor have
lined the pockets of their wealthy pals
whilst upwards of 175 thousand of our
fellow citizens have died from kovid and
they're now sitting on their hands and
laughing in our faces as the cost of
living crisis and fuel poverty could
well leave thousands more to die of cold
in their own homes so mr speaker
when we saw pictures of the pm partying
in the middle of the pandemic was he
toasting his assault on the working
class and i asked him
how on earth does he sleep at night with
so much blood on his filthy privileged
hands
[Applause]
mr speaker uh from from furlough onwards
everything we have done since the
pandemic began has been to get uh money
into the pockets of the working people
of this country and those are the people
those are the people time and again uh
that we have prioritized and i do not
for a moment i do not for a moment doubt
mr speaker the things that things are
tough i do not doubt it for a moment but
it's our intention to get this country
through it and we will get through it
very well by putting our arms around
people as we can and as we will because
of the fiscal firepower that we have mr
speaker but also by making sure that we
continue with the high wage high skill
high employment economy that we have and
the best thing for to get money to
people's pockets mr speaker is to have a
job